hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great day not this game here it comes
as a suggestion from several subscribers
and it does make sense to cover such a
game by the winner of the Reykjavik open
Bhaskar an Audubon and as we do have
time all of yesterday's games in the
candidates finished with a draw although
that are none glitch to game was
extremely interesting but we should
definitely cover it now I always
mentioned this well the first time I saw
a game but bhaskar another bond the
first time he came onto the big big
scene maybe not the first time but the
first time I noticed him was in the Tata
Steel tournament when he faced Westley
so and he opened the game with the white
pieces and he played the Kings gambit so
that game ended in a draw but
nevertheless it was a very exciting game
and I knew that
bhaskaran audubon definitely is a very
interesting player so here he faces a
Richard report and this is the final
round of the Reykjavik open tournament
and prior to the last round both of them
had six and a half points so it's a
fairly sure that whoever wins this game
will be the winner of the Reykjavik open
tournament now I couldn't find the photo
of the two of them from the Reykjavik
tournament but I did find a photo of the
two of them playing in the Tata Steel
tournament and it was also in the final
round with Tata Steel tournament and
bhaskaran won that game but okay that
being said let's see this game so Ally
bond opens with d4 we have d5 and c4 c6
the Slav defense Knight to f3 Knight f6
Knight to c3 and D captures on c4 c4 and
now the immediate b5 so we've entered
the gallery gambit and here if white
would proceed with ePHI we would go into
the main variation but re-bond goes for
Bishop to e2 so now II 6 pushing before
here doesn't really achieve anything for
black you can win d4 pawn but after
Knight a 4 you can capture it but white
can simply need immediately capture on
on on c4 and as you don't really have a
deep one anymore and the b-pawn well you
do have it but it's um before the white
knight will have a night outpost and c5
so not really much for black here so
after Bishop to e2 6
we have castles Bishop to e7 and now a
for immediately trying to break that
pawn structure on the Queen side b4 and
here moving the knight really makes no
sense moving right to it - huh and any
square would be terrible for white the
only move is a 5 so we have B captures
on c3 e captures on f6 Bishop captures
on f6 and B captors on c3 and now Bishop
to a6 guarding that c4 pawn Knight to e5
and this is definitely the first
critical moment of the game that night
and e5 is extremely annoying you kind of
don't want to give your dark square
bishop for this night but on the other
hand you don't want to leave it on e5 so
what are blacks options here the best
idea for black is to actually give up
the c6 pawn but it's hard to make such a
decision for example if you develop the
knight then this Knight can capture on
c6 this would in fact be blacks best
option after Knight to d7 allowing
Knight captures on c6 and after Queen to
c7 attacking the knight Knight goes to B
for attacks the bishop and after Bishop
to b7 black would definitely have
counter play here with with also having
the bishop pair this Bishop on b7 is
it's a very nice piece and the game goes
on here after 95 rapper 2 decided to
immediately capture it Bishop captures
on e5 we have D captures on e5 and the
Queen captures on d1 rook captures on d1
and now Knight to d7 attacking d5 pawn
we have f4 here and now Knight to b6
guarding this c4 pawn twice but more
importantly trying to reach this d5
square if this night ever gets the d5
blacks position will be fine
but Audubon doesn't allow it he plays
the immediate rook to d6 attacking the
c6 pawn and here you do have quite a lot
of options for black it's very hard to
decide that what to do as you do have a
double C pawn those pawns are very weak
if white grabs both of them could be
scary so here you could play a move like
rook to b7 sauger ship to b7 try and
defended but
rook to be 105 is coming and it's a very
uncomfortable position for blacks Bishop
another thing you could try something
like c5 but this would lose the game
immediately as a 5 you have to move the
knight and you lose the bishop on a5 and
a6 another thing you could try and play
rook to c8 simply defend it this way but
after Bishop to f3 attacking this twice
Bishop to b7 now you can play Bishop to
e3 and again a white white will prevail
here if 5 is not a 5 is coming Bishop
captures and a 7 is coming there
definitely a good position for white so
after this rook to d6 we have castles
and by report so ok getting ready to
bring the other rook into the game
Bishop to f3 it's not about winning the
c6 pawn the c6 pawn will fall eventually
but it's important for this bishop to
assume the position on f3 to control
this very strong diagonal and here again
it's a very critical position black has
to played the most precise moves to to
maintain equality here or at least try
to maintain it and here nice to d5 would
be the best defense for black for
example Knight to d5 you give up the c6
pawn bishop to b7 now activating this
bishop allowing white to capture even
the c4 pawn so after rook captures now
look at the c8 and after rook captures
rook captures now Bishop to d2 defending
this pawn but what I can even capture it
not not immediately but first bishop to
a6 putting this bishop on a nice square
and now you're controlling this pawn
this point cannot be pushed to c4 if
white wants to prevent this pawn from
being captured heater has to play rook
to c1 after which black can set up a
nice blockade or or he has to give up
the bishop pair and then black will be
able to equalize but after this bishop
to have to remove a Richard report made
a move this is only move 17 but here he
actually makes a move that loses the
game here he played Knight to c8
he he had a different idea here rook
captures on
was played Bishop to be seven and this
was Robert's idea now if for example you
move the rook rook to c5
then simply Bishop Kuiper's on f3 g
captors on f3 and rope to d8 would a
tactic now if white goes on and grabs
the c4 pawn and rook to d1 will give
black a lot of activity this was
probably his idea I don't think I don't
think he actually missed
ah demons killer move but here of course
a demon didn't move the rook to c7 or c5
here are the other one played rook
captures on c8 now it's hard to say if
Robert actually missed this move if any
of you saw any interviews from this game
from the Reykjavik open to sharing the
comments maybe he just didn't find that
nice defense with the Knight to d5 would
giving that both of the pawns but yeah
now of course if you capture with the
bishop you lose the rook here you don't
really have the option of capturing the
bishop first because then rook captures
with check in captures pawn captures and
now you're up a whole piece so after
this row captors on c8 Robert played
rook captures on see it and now Bishop
captures some b7 now Audubon has a
bishop pair for a rook and this is
completely winning here rook to b8 was
played Bishop to e6 now rook to b3
trying to grab that c3 pawn at least
gain something and now not the the
passive defense with Bishop to d2 rather
he plays a bishop to a3 he attacks a
report Sorokin f8 we have rope to d8 and
now Bishop to b4 attacking it this way
and now the only thing White has to
prevent is something like rook to d2
rook to be 2 with some perpetual
checking ideas but he does that here
rook to d2 was played now we have Bishop
characters on c4 as Audubon definitely
has the time to even grab a pawn rook to
be 2 and now Bishop to f1 and now this
bishop is completely safe guarding the
White King here the rooks are powerless
against it
h5 was played here a5 simply controlling
all of the points on the Queen side so
no funny business can happen a 6 here
Bishop to c5 and here after upper plate
g6 it was in this position
he resigned the game he resigned it okay
sometimes two rooks a rook can come to
bishops but definitely not in this
position as blacks plan is fairly simple
he will simply move the dark square
Bishop make room for his past C pawn and
now the C pawn largest of the board
black really doesn't have anything to do
here he can simply wait he can move the
rook now c-4 is coming the bishop in an
f1 is not only guarding the King but
also safeguarding the past pawn you have
to move the rook now even rook c1 is
possible putting a rope behind the past
pawn and if black would try to maybe
gain some counter play by capturing and
the Queen side doesn't really matter c5
but can't even capture it now c6 is
coming rook has to started the pawn but
now c7 rook stops the pawn and now c8
simply wins the game
of course the endgame can continue
another way but it's one of the way one
of the ways it could happen so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
it was a it was quite a quite an intense
last round as like I said both of them
had six and a half points before the
last round and whoever won it will win
the Reykjavik open and Richard report
also had some very exciting games in
this tournament his round 7 victory over
Alexander Lenderman was also a very nice
game so yeah it I mean you get the black
pieces against the Audubon and like I
said I did one really really is deadly
with the white pieces so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I almost
forgot I prepared the final standings of
the tournament for you so you can also
check that out here we have buscar' an
Audubon first place with seven and a
half out of nine then Maxime lagarde
Mustafa Yuma's gotta calm skin fourth
and so on and so on
I think Richard Robert got 10th place
here you have in Indian superstar Ramesh
Babu pregnant on 13th and I believe I
believe Nicholson is in 21st place which
is definitely a brilliant result and and
out of 247 players that totally
participated in the tournament you know
it's always good to be in the top 20 so
yeah I do
I enjoyed it I would like to thank Don
Dugan for a contribution to my channel
thank a lot I really appreciate that as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon